talking about attempted attacks some
murders happening against Israelis in
Africa and several other places what can
you tell us and what's your first
impression when you see this I'm not
surprised I've spent most the last year
covering al Qaeda cells in Europe
primarily in France Belgium Spain some
work in England and then North Africa
and from all of the intelligence chiefs
that I've interviewed consistently
throughout the past year they have felt
that these kinds of attacks are
inevitable and indeed they worry about
much more catastrophic attacks I think
what a lot of people forget is that the
attacks of 911 took two years to plan
and there's a group of very dedicated
capable people capable in the sense of
being able to commit acts of terrorism
out there in Europe the French estimate
that about 400 French dual nationals one
must remember there are four million nor
primarily North African Muslims that
live in France have made their way back
to Europe from Afghanistan and it's a
matter of regrouping setting up new
cells but especially the French are very
very worried so it's not a surprise
there's no question in your mind that
this is al Qaeda well that is of course
for the intelligence community's to
determine but it has all the
fingerprints of al Qaeda yeah I mean one
must remember that al Qaeda is not it's
not the National Rifle Association
people don't walk around carrying
membership cards it's a much more
amorphous and a loser kind of network
and al Qaeda cells I when we look at for
instance the Paris Embassy bombing plot
that was broken by the French they were
given fairly amorphous orders from
Afghanistan from the leadership even in
terms of time table in terms of how they
were going to do it in terms of who they
were going to recruit so these cells
have a lot of autonomy they tend not to
after a particular attack they tend to
dissipate and form new groups new small
cells they're very prodean they change
shape of the chief investigating judge
in France brugera says it's like the
AIDS virus
you know they constantly mutate and for
that reason they're very hard to track
down and very hard to control because
the there's minimal contact between them
and the al Qaeda leadership they have a
lot of autonomy with the new york times
since 1990 and prior to that in the
Middle East for the Dallas Morning News
to wear where have you I was haunted
from I've I was overseas for 15-plus
years six years in Latin America spent
five years covering the war in El
Salvador Nicaragua took a sabbatical to
study Arabic went to the Middle East for
the Dallas Morning News covered all of
the Middle East and then the collapse of
the communist regimes in East Germany
Czechoslovakia and Romania worked in
India and Africa was hired by the new
york times in 1990 covered the Gulf War
and then in 1991 I became the Middle
East bureau chief for The New York Times
based in Cairo and then the Balkan
bureau chief covered the war in in
Sarajevo and unco ssible and when you
say covered the war how did how did you
do that in the Balkans in any of these
places oh I I lived I didn't go in and
out I live there and I lived in san
salvador and i was in sorry if i had a
room in a Holiday Inn like the other the
other journalists were they are covering
the war was right right in the thick of
it I mean I was in the middle of the
fighting what does this beam this title
of your new book war is a force that
gives us meaning i had always liked and
been very influenced by a book by the
historian crane britain anatomy of a
revolution where he had tried to dissect
generically what is it that creates
revolution what are the he looked at
several revolutions to do that so it so
remains for me a fascinating book and i
wanted to do the same thing with war I
wanted to and I've covered you know a
dozen conflicts I've spent I was a
seminarian so I thought about this in in
moral and ethical terms you know I had
to read Just War theory and Christian
ethicists from Nibiru Bart
and I wanted to do the same thing for
war what what creates the disease of war
within a society what are the factors
that do it how does war come about how
does were corrupt both individuals and
societies how does it work and so I
spent I took a fellowship at Harvard and
that's where it really began and I began
to piece it all together and that's what
I attempted to do more forms its own
culture war as a drug yes yeah it does
form its own culture it's a subculture
which makes it so fascinating and it has
I think like any kind of extreme
activity it has a kind of intoxication
not only for societies that support a
war that go into war but for the
participants themselves it has a very
it's a very dark and frightening elixir
even with its destruction you're right
and it's carnage it can give us what we
long for in life yes it in on many
levels it banishes the sort of trivial
in a common place it enables us it
raises us to to create this kind of this
communal sense of bonding this this kind
of corporate sense this comradeship or
suddenly we feel at one Elias Canadian
crowds and power writes about this you
know where suddenly when you have that
external threat one feels as part of a
whole and any rights and I think
correctly that death becomes easier to
bear or the threat of death because one
fit no longer faces it alone you know
you you give up individual consciousness
for the the goals of the war enterprise
and which reduces I think a lot of
common anxiety I mean there there there
is in war unfortunately especially for
people in modern society who often are
profoundly alone and and live very
atomized there is a more a sense of
belonging a sense of purpose that can
escape people in everyday life more from
your book war fills our spiritual void I
do not miss war but I miss what it
brought
I can never say I was happy in the midst
of the fighting in El Salvador Bosnia
Kosovo but I had a sense of purpose of
calling and this is a quality that war
shares with love as we are in love also
able to choose fealty and self-sacrifice
over security yes war at its inception
always looks and feels like love the
chief emotion that war destroys and you
know the the ancient Greeks and Romans
understood that war was a god and that
war called at the beginning for the
sacrifice for others but war
uncontrolled uninspected untamed ends
with self-sacrifice self-annihilation
and that's why it's so dangerous phone
lines are open for christopher hedges if
you'd like to join us Democrats 2025 853
881 Republicans 2025 853 880 and all
others 2025 85 3882 so you and about
this as understanding that this was
going to be kind of an unusual type of
war book a war reporting book yes it's
not a war reporting book I never really
liked narratives by journalists about
even I thought that there's a very dark
side to what we do and I find that you
know in the press in wartime are is part
of the myth making machine and always
has been and journalists are not only
good at at sustaining the national myth
but the myth about themselves so the
points where I did bring myself up or I
did pull sort of anecdotes from land I
tried to be very hard on myself and on
the profession because this is about the
disease of war yeah it's it's it's it's
certainly not a traditional book in any
sense it's it's a meditation on war the
notion I think I found where did the
notion that the press was used in the
war I think you're talking about the
gulf war hero is incorrect the press
wanted to be used it saw itself as part
of the war effort that well that's
always been true the pre-code the first
casualty taking this quote from all the
senator on Walker about the first
casualty in wars truth
and he looked at the way nationalist
pressed reporting on their own conflicts
from the Crimea war up through the
present day and in every single conflict
the press sees itself as part of the war
effort as as an entity which must sort
of sustain the morale and support the
cause Chris Hedges our guests from the
New York Times will go to the phones Los
Angeles first up good morning hi good
morning and happy thanksgiving i am sure
you thought a lot about this in the
course of writing your book and i'm sure
you also had to grapple with the issue
of what you know what war does that's
also good and that might be antithetical
to your your book but certainly we have
to look back and see that good things
also were accomplished and i'm not
championing war but i immediately I'm
thinking as you're talking about the
choice during World War Two for example
to ultimately destroy the will of
Germany and Japan to continue fighting
we recognize the need to I don't know
another word but exterminate the will to
launch these genocide alors and we did
it and that strikes me as a terribly
good outcome of war and I might have a
follow-up I'd like to listen to your
response thanks i had illustrations yes
i'm not a pacifist i think that war is a
tragic and inevitable part of the human
condition but i don't believe that there
there is a good war war some wars have
to be fought i supported the
intervention in bosnia i supported the
intervention in Kosovo I feel that we
failed as a country by not intervening
in Rwanda when you have the capacity to
stop genocide and if we learn anything
from the Holocaust we should have
learned this and you do not you are in
some way culpable but war is always
tragic and war wreaks do not only a
physical devastation but a psychological
and emotional devastation that takes
generations to heal so certainly I
understand why we fought
war two was the outcome good you know
Reinhold Niebuhr the great Christian
Ephesus wrote that moral choices very
rarely almost never probably between
what is moral and what is immoral but
what is a one immoral choice and one
more immoral choice and for me that's
the moment when you have to choose war
you're choosing an immoral choice over
an option which can be of course
appeasement or the failure to act as a
more immoral choice so and I lived my
father and all of my most of my uncle's
fought in the war one of whom was
devastated by the war in the south
pacific and that was a burden that my
family many families carried him there
was and there was there is no good war
many journalists if it get affected by
the war yes many war correspondents tend
to be their own fraternity and they
wander from war zone to war zone so that
I was covering the war in kosovo with
people who I had covered the war with in
El Salvador 20 years before and that's
part of their sickness you know aid
workers have it of course combat
soldiers soldiers to have it and that's
they they need the rush of war they have
a hard time coping in peacetime society
they they're very traumatized by it and
news organizations have never been
particularly good at knowing how to
handle that so a lot of them come back
with drinking problems friends of mine
especially after the war in Bosnia that
was so brutal have never recovered you
mentioned a specific story in a book of
someone who didn't didn't make it after
coming home who was it well I there a
couple instances in the book of people
who didn't make it including the end of
the book where I talk about my friend
Kurt schork it was a Reuters
correspondent was killed in Sierra Leone
along with Miguel Gil Moreno and there
there was I talk about a photographer in
the book who had covered the war in El
Salvador and tried to give it up and
came back and and couldn't and
essentially we knew when he came back
that he'd come back to die sterling
virginia your next republican a good
morning how are you thank you for the
opportunity to speak with mr. Rogers I
mr. actors who said you were in Sarah
gay
during the conflict now in 1995 we bond
the Bosnian Serbs over what was
described as the margalla marketplace
massacre however your zippo danske in
this book and I'm breathing directly
from his book says that this was a self
callous self killing which was designed
to shock the West especially sentimental
and gullible Washington in order to
raise a level Western sympathy to
Bosnian Muslims and further demonize the
Serbs now my question is we continually
lied about the atrocities committed over
there the dance key is a very honorable
man he said that the bomb that was used
to bomb the amar color marketplace was
designed with the help of Hezbollah now
the al-qaeda has been in there for over
a decade and there we just had to serve
the right to defend themselves and I
would like to follow up on your answer
well that's a caller we have a lot of
folks on the line so we'll just take
your question thank you I don't I looked
at that market place bombing and and
this has been a persistent claim on the
part of the Serbs that this bomb was
designed by Hezbollah or designed by the
Muslims themselves there's no evidence
to support that the UN carried out a
long investigation you know the fact is
there were 1,000 2,000 heavy shells
coming into sorry avo daily and the
notion that you know that somehow the
Serbs would not have said well let's not
put shells there there's a marketplace
is patently absurd those shells landed
all over the place including on
hospitals so that that's just not true
and i think the other misconception is
that we went into sorry able because of
the marketplace bombing we went into
sorry Avon this is all in Richard
Holbrook's book because the UN mission
was collapsing and and President Clinton
had made a commitment to NATO that if
there was an extraction of forces UN as
our US soldiers would go in to help with
that extraction rather than do that
because they worried about suffering
heavy casualties they decided to bomb
that's why we went in we went in to save
the UN mission because it was falling
apart Thank You Ellen oh I democrat good
morning and thanks for see spam and the
opportunity to speak with mr. hedges
I have a question I have an opinion on
it and then I'd like to see what you
think about it or your answer to it it
kind of ties together this segment with
the last one we've just had events in
2001 brought us to war were likely to go
into further war and in the last segment
they brought up the investigation and an
investigation that will be conducted on
it in a large number of the calls
concerned conspiracy theories and they
did it like the fact that it was
Kissinger and and Michael de Mitchell
looking into it because of their past
politics my question is an investigation
is going to be done and but that seems
to me to be like likening being upset
that a better make a former politician
would investigate a crime in a city
because he might have helped produce
poverty that create that creates crime
and it seems to me this investigation
isn't about the causes of the of what
happened it's not about that the root
causes and whatnot it has to do with
finding out who did it how they did it
how we keep it from happening again and
I'm wondering if do you believe do you
think that this it was an overwhelming
number of calls in that area and I want
to know if you find any validity to
their criticism that these people
consider Mitchell are not qualified to
do that based on their politics that's
an interesting question of course Henry
Kissinger having spent six years in
Latin America and covered Chile myself
is a very controversial figure I think
you're right to point out that what this
is is an intelligence failure and what
the inability to capture Osama bin Laden
and break the leadership of al Qaeda is
as well as an intelligence failure and
yes certainly a figure especially I
think bye-bye mr. Kissinger certainly
figured by doc like dr. Kissinger is
pretty suspect but that doesn't mean
they can't find people on their staff
who have that expertise to do it I
wouldn't be so quick to dismiss the
effort but I think the questions are
valid ones next is Chicago Republican
good morning honey
create as a really diffuse organization
how do you think the best way would be
to find and defeat it and even if we do
defeat Al Qaeda is that enough to
safeguard our security what about groups
like Hezbollah and related groups al
Qaeda is a is different from many of the
other terrorist groups you know I
al-qaeda came out of the the nationalist
Islamic movements in the Middle East for
instance the feasts and the GI a and
Algeria but they brought together people
from various countries and no longer
were they concerned primarily for
instance like the GI a the armed Islamic
group and Algeria with the so-called
liberation of Algeria the creation of
Islamic state but a much more nihilistic
kind of rage against everything Western
so how do you fight al-qaeda it really
has to be two prong on the one hand it
is a very difficult intelligence war one
of the complaints the French make about
the American intelligence community is
that we don't have enough human assets
we rely too much on electronic
surveillance satellite photos that kind
of stuff and they the French who are
very good because one must remember in
the 1980s that the GI was setting off
bombs in the Paris Metro and in bank
robbing banks and shooting policemen I
mean there was real havoc for and they
and they really successfully broke the
GI a and they did it through
old-fashioned intelligence work i mean
if for instance in their wiretaps when
they when they are following a suspected
sell their 23 different dialects Arabic
dialects in Algeria and they have
real-time translators in each one of
those dialects they have just set up an
operation that and that that allows them
to get real-time information and then
they have worked assiduously at
infiltrating people in
to various terrorist networks and they
feel that the Americans because they
didn't do that then have that's one of
the reasons for the intelligence
failures the French say that every time
they have broken a plot it has not been
through primarily through electronic
he's dropping but through being tipped
off by by people that they had inside
the organizations or close to the
organization's i think the other
frightening thing is that we still can't
read a lot of the traffic that al-qaeda
is sending back and forth it it's very
sophisticated it's although the French
have a lot of disks so one sees the
arrests now over these men who had
assisted read and the the shoe bomber
who had stopped in Paris but they've had
those disks for months and it's taken
them quite a when I last time I was in
Paris they still hadn't decipher them so
we're dealing with people who have a
level of technical expertise that's far
beyond as well the homegrown Islamic
movements that we have seen before page
80 of your boot new book the destruction
of culture plays a crucial role in the
solidification of a wartime narrative
when the visible and tangible symbols of
one's past are destroyed or denied the
past can be recreated to fit the myth
and I guess I take you to today's news
stories which is not it's not a tangible
thing but some might say it's something
that's no longer going to be had and
that is that there's going to be a
request that the federal government pay
for all the security for both the
Democratic and Republican conventions in
2004 is that is that a part of the
culture that is just going away not
necessarily the paying for it but the
whole idea of how we oversee security
yes I think I'm talking more I think
that is part of it but I think I'm
speaking more about sort of let's call
it authentic or dissident culture and
one sees and once saw this after nine
eleven that cultural events become
infused with the jingoism of patriotism
and that's very dangerous I mean one of
the things that I've learned by covering
various conflicts there's you know we
had that issue
you of cultural genocide in Bosnia where
the Serbs would dynamite mosques and of
course they destroyed the great library
in Sarajevo but what people forget is
that in wartime the destruction of
culture always begins with the
destruction of one's own culture that in
wartime we are forced to speak with a
language the state gives us the nation
gives us the cliches the axis of evil
showdown with Iraq and it becomes very
hard to express yourself outside the box
there is a hijacking of language in
wartime that's very frightening so
whatever disquiet you have your robbed
of the vocabulary to express it and this
isn't an esoteric idea because until you
can recreate a common narrative there is
no peace if you go to a country like
Bosnia or Cyprus you don't have peace
what you have is the absence of war
because there is no common in common
narrative by which people can
communicate mean the the entities in
Bosnia in the schools teach radically
different versions of the same
historical event and what they're doing
is grooming a new generation that can no
longer speak with each other the truth
and reconciliation commission that was
set up in South Africa was absolutely
vital because although of course it gave
an amnesty to the killers who had
carried out these crimes for the
apartheid regime in order to get that
amnesty they had to lay bare what they
did the crimes that they had committed
and it makes it that much harder to deny
it and it gives people a way to speak
back and forth around a common reality
so that's what I'm talking about the
destruction of culture is in the
hijacking of language which of course I
you know have two chapters in my book
that deal precisely with those themes
are are very pernicious and very
frightening aspects of a wartime society
and I see that happening within our own
society Bruce most society mr. hedges
writes never recover from the
self-inflicted wounds made by their own
culture during wartime war leaves behind
not memory but amnesia next call
Kalamazoo Michigan Democrat morning
Kalamazoo good morning mr. hedges good
morning I would like to
you kind of sparked my mind when you
were talking about culture and it
reminded me when Jon Walters was on
c-span I believe last week and he was
saying that they feels that they
successfully now driven the culture in
the drug war underground enough to
really attack and I can see that mr.
Hitchens son the DEA man is going to be
put in charge of transportation in the
border and mr. Walters announced that
they're going to be stopping cars and
giving a test for marijuana usage and
that means that any metabolites found in
an individual it will be grounds to give
him a DWI and what I'd like to say is
that the FBI just released its figures
on arrests for marijuana possession and
it was 700,000 people arrested last year
for just possession now you see Nevada
tried to vote for three ounces and
legalize it and tax it through the
government and they got forty percent of
the vote and yet we never see any
responsible people being asked to come
on and defend that on the c-span thank
you for the call Kalamazoo next is Boca
Raton Florida yes good morning morning
uh I think we all have you know a
philosophical repugnance for war I you
know again I'm reminded that you know
Hagel did say that philosophy was a
focaccia felt it was a world stood on
its head my concern is that we are in a
war that has been thrust upon us I mean
we we are dealing with fanatic Islamists
who abide by the laws of who dabaya the
treaties of kourosh wherein no treaty
with an infidel needs to be honored
where there is an actual la injunction
that it can be and should be abrogated
as soon as victory is in sight and my
concern is that there is a knife
a in American diplomacy and and Western
diplomacy that we can negotiate with
these individuals who perceive us is I
think the latest thing that I saw was
that we are pigs or monkeys and that we
we are to be destroyed and and
ultimately I think when you have
kulturkampf you hear you have to support
your your you know what remains even
after war as you indicated there may be
there may be a you know a subversion of
our own culture but again subversion
perhaps is is a preferable to a
disruption of it and and my concern here
is that this is the the behind this
wahhabism this is this approach to to I
think that we should do as Kennedy did
during the Cuban Missile Crisis I think
we should make the the Arab states that
support these these terrorists I think
we should make them responsible that if
an attack on the United States or its
allies is waged against us that they
must pay a price they support them
militarily they support them financially
why not make them pay a price for their
you know for for their habit thank you
oh yeah i mean the caller raises two
issues that disturb me and that is this
tendency to make vast sweeping
generalizations about the muslim world
which constitutes one-fifth of the
world's population most muslims of
course are not Arabs and yes the people
arrayed against us call us infidels and
other names and we call them barbarians
we cannot become like them and we cannot
assume that they somehow represent the
tens of millions of Muslims who share
the same kind of repugnance that we do
towards these terrorists Islam is a
nuanced diverse rich tradition or
religion that can't be summed up in in
cliches just like you can about
any of the monotheistic other
monotheistic faiths such as Judaism or
Christianity and Islam unfortunately has
seen a radical fundamentalist movement
but so has Christianity and so has
Judaism you know Jerry Falwell doesn't
speak for me so I feel that you know to
somehow make sweeping generalizations
against the muslims or islam in this
kind of environment is dangerous and it
it in many ways smacks of what those
arrayed against us are doing secondly in
terms of the war this is not a war you
can't declare war against an idea you
can declare war against a nation you can
declare war against Iraq the war on
terror comes out of or well it's this
amorphous never-ending battle that those
who wage the war define they define who
the war is arrayed against they define
how long it will go and what is what is
victory against the war on terror this
is an intelligence battle and it has to
be waged by intelligence services
unfortunately our intelligence agencies
failed us with 911 and they failed us in
many ways in Afghanistan as you see with
the Israelis of with black September it
takes years to track these people down
and it's very difficult dropping iron
fragmentation bombs all over the place
is the worst way to go after a war on
terror because it only creates more
terrorists it has to be the war any kind
of a battle against these kind of
elements has to be waged on two fronts
one by the intelligence community but
secondly politically we can't fold in on
ourselves there has to be a recognition
that that did take place at the end of
the Persian Gulf War and then
unfortunately was never followed through
that there you know many people have
legitimate grievances against us or
against the client states that we
support i'm thinking of course of the
Palestinians or Egyptians or many Saudis
were very there's a great deal of
discontent over the Saudi royal families
rule of Saudi Arabia and unfortunately
in wartime with the rhetoric it
precludes self reflection and self in
respek Shin which is always very
dangerous because it only fuels the
violence and fuels the antagonism this
email question is any anti war effort a
war well one of the dangers with anti
war efforts and this comes directly out
of the First World War is there it there
is a tendency to believe that we can
employ the instruments of war to end war
and war is always a disease and just as
a cancer patient may have to ingest a
poison to fight off cancer there are
times when a society has to ingest the
poison of war in order to survive but it
is a poison always a poison and it
doesn't matter whether that's that
poison is ingested for a good or a bad
cause it's the same poison so I would
caution against people who want to fight
war with war next is Park Forest
Illinois morning Chris good morning I
didn't think I know maybe you mentioned
where Christmas book is available well
let's see it is published by public
affairs which is based in New York City
and it is probably available nationwide
yes any barnes and nobles borders amazon
ok good i guess i forget which
philosopher greek philosopher was is
that we make war so that we may live in
peace and one gentleman was so used so
many big words i don't know i understood
half of it just previously but anyway i
look at it from a very simplistic point
i look at the freedoms that I work with
Jew Muslim Christian agnostic and
everybody basically in this country
still can practice as they want do what
they want and live live in my opinion of
free life and you as an American
brightness book I'm interested to know
how that affected you in terms of
writing this book but basically that
that being said i look at it very simply
is there's a choice now we either go
after these people uh or we surrender to
them so they made it pretty easy in my
opinion we're gone after him and and
like you said you don't want to serve a
call to war but a war is a war against
terrorism so I'd like to know your input
in terms of how you as an American uh
that affected you in writing this book
in if in fact it did
well I don't have any problem going
after them the question is how we go
after them and what we embrace as a
society as we go after them if we
embrace the same kind of intolerance the
same kind of chauvinism then we become
little better than we don't become any
different I mean I worry about the
rhetoric I worry about the the way we
are portraying the Muslim world you know
people have all sorts of opinions having
really knowing very very little about
Islam and very little about Muslim
culture I have a great deal of respect
for for Islam you know I'm hardly a
scholar but you know I I do speak Arabic
I have lived for seven years in the
Middle East there you know the the
religion along with Judaism and
Christianity in my mind is one of the
great religions of the world and to see
it slam like this if I were a Muslim I
would just be furious and and
heartbroken and and that worries me
these vast generalizations and that and
you know war always begins with language
and it is the dehumanization of the
other the turning of the other
linguistically into an object and once
they become an object linguistically
it's not a huge step to turn them into
an object literally ieo corpse and we
can't fight that battle we can't you
know that we can't clash to steal a
phrase from Samuel Huntington with
another civilization because there's no
need to and it really is done out of
ignorance and I think just as they
attack us out of ignorance and and for
that reason of course you can't
compromise with them or negotiate with
them I'm talking about these small
terrorist cells at the same time we we
have to rise above it and we have to
embrace the values that have given us
our freedoms and that plurality and that
respect for others which has made our
country in many ways unique in the
annals of civilization but I see in
every war time that is always corrosive
always corroded and it's being corroded
now and and it worries me and in the
event of another terrorist attack
especially possibly a cataclysmic attack
I think we will see a further swing
towards this kind of intolerance
and this kind of racism and this kind of
bigotry and this thirst for violence and
if there is you know one lesson on the
globe or maybe two that will point to
the fact that you cannot quash the
national or the rage of a populist
purely through violence look at Chechnya
or look at what's happening between the
Israelis and the Palestinians those you
know that you end up shattering any kind
of discourse pushing societies into
extremes where they no longer can speak
it's the only way they speak is through
the act of violence itself and then
everyone's doomed well is there a finger
a point of blame for the evolution of
this of this language is a journalist is
that the politicians who is it I think
the press bears culpability for it
certainly the state does excuse me the
entertainment industry does it it
becomes in wartime an alternative
language is pretty much drowned out and
you know you saw that with people who
tried to raise questions about the you
know the wild sort of patriotic embrace
that followed 911 they were pretty
roundly attacked and that's subsided
somewhat but if we get another terrorist
attack on American soil those kinds of
dissident voices will be drowned out
Chicago your next Democratic good
morning oh good morning practice happy
things giving to all I sure what your
piece and the Harper magazine little
over a year ago and paddled a Gaza diary
was when if you tell a little bit more
about experience specifically at the
time and I was wondering in your mind
you see our warrant tourism equivalent
to the Israelis against the Palestinian
culture pink elephants you've done
several things for things for Harper's
including a diary I went and lived in a
refugee camp in Gaza called honey Eunice
and I wrote the cover story for Harper's
and it was on a day to day sometimes
literally morning by afternoon what it
was like to be a Palestinian who lived
in this refugee camp and it was a pretty
Syrian in the end ended up being a very
Syrian indictment of the way the Israeli
Defense Forces and the settlers
in Israel itself were treating
Palestinian refugees in Gaza you know I
was every single day I was there there
was shooting often towards small
children young as young as 10 or 11 you
know and then I would visit them in the
hospital later and is there a no I don't
think that we this is what I don't want
to happen I think that what's happening
in between the Palestinians and the
Israelis is this complete embrace of
necrophilia on both sides and everything
has become every every act of violence
is countered by another act of violence
if there's a suicide bombing on a bus
then you bomb a refugee camp and this is
only with each side dumping gasoline all
over the conflict and as we've seen I
mean look at what's happened for the
last two years the Israeli economy has
tanked the numbers of Israeli dead are
growing of course three times as many
Palestinians have been killed and once
you get into this spiral it's very very
hard to turn back and that is what I
don't think we're there yet I think that
if we come under assault I don't think
the Israelis are somehow reacting any
differently than any other society would
but I think that if we did come under
assault I would worry that and that's
part of the reason why I wrote this book
is that you know I I don't want us to
see I want us to to open our eyes and
see the disease and the danger of this
kind of rhetoric and these kinds of
emotions that are unleashed by conflict
so that we can guard against them
because it ends while it looks like the
destruction of the other if it's not
checked it ends with self-destruction
fremont indiana i wish you a healthy and
contemplative and peaceful day and i
hope that for more people in our country
because there's too much of this self
driven attitude i really appreciate the
service that mr. hedges is providing and
I would add that war is also force that
distracts people from realizing their
need to see life as needing to be a
growth continuum and I go to the
President and say wait a minute I don't
see leadership here even though I voted
for you and I
I like to say I'm a Republican but
sometimes I cringe when I see people
like Karl Rove acting like a dictator
and I can't get two words in except on
c-span and talk radio and I believe I'm
being principled and pleasant in
suggesting that there needs to be a
streamlining of business as the mutual
fund certainly no top to bottom to have
what dr. Deming talked about and that is
the resource most underused the working
person respected and brought into
decision-making when streamlining and
and upgrading and improvements are made
otherwise we're not being patriotic
we're not able to defend ourselves in
the economy that is coming after us
including China mr. hedges yeah well
it's a question of leadership that of
course has to be something that that's
perhaps not for me to judge you know the
only thing I would say is that we the
way that we have responded to the
terrorist threat is to build an alliance
a kind of troika with Putin and sharone
and I think many people forget that much
of the world especially the Muslim world
sees us through the prism of Palestine
and Chechnya and what they see is very
unsavory so rather than engage in the
kind of introspection that perhaps we
should engage in and rather question the
policies as we're carrying them out
we're folding in on ourselves and
embracing to people who have I think
very very questionable responses to
homegrown insurrections of course now we
have Putin and schron quite avidly
describing these conflicts in this as in
the same terms that we describe what
we're going through and I think in fact
they're different i think what what's
happening in chechnya or what's
happening in the West Bank and Gaza is
not the same as what's happening to us
and by allowing them to use the same
kind of rhetoric and and and carry out
their kinds of policies without any kind
of real core
scizzum from Washington or real
questioning throws us in with a group of
or let's see two leaders that perhaps we
don't want to be thrown in with
Washington DC Democrat hi Michael um I'm
an American Muslim and I have been
concerned about our inability to
differentiate between friend and foe
after 911 I was not worried about a
clash of civilizations now I am for the
simple reason that I'm asked by friends
here sincerely why do they hate us and I
can understand that and I try to explain
that but now when I go to my parents
Middle East I'm asked over there why do
the Americans hate us and that's coming
from what they read about the Christian
Right salami slamming Islam and that
worries me because that's the mainstream
that's what people on both sides are
thinking so looking at your thoughts
thank you well I think you touched
exactly on a point I raised earlier in
that justice Osama bin Laden does not
speak for you indeed does not speak for
the vast majority of Muslims Jerry
Falwell and Pat Robertson do not speak
for me and I say this as a as a former
seminarian so I I think that just as
perhaps many Muslims in the Middle East
are ignorant about Christianity what its
tenants are who it spokespeople are we
are ignorant as well to very ignorant
about Islam and and the only way to
bridge that the only way to to build to
reach out to the other is by
understanding the other Martin Luther
King had a wonderful quote he said I can
never be who I ought to be until you are
who you ought to be and you can never be
who you ought to be until I am Who I
ought to be and I think that by
respecting the dignity of the other and
and and honoring the traditions of the
other is the only way in which we can
can fight this and that understanding
only comes not by swallowing the facile
and frankly racist cliches that are
peddled by both sides but by taking the
time to study
to understand to reach out to speak and
unfortunately in wartime society that
becomes harder to do front page of your
newspaper today talks about the United
States is pressing for Turkey to help in
the move to Iraq and I ask you that
because of the recent elections in
Turkey the fact that the Islamic groups
to help take our taking I having more of
a power in turn right so how does that
work with when we're talking about our
allies not just our enemies right I
think what people forget about Islamic
movements in the Middle East is that
they're nationally based and and a good
analogy comes with a communism of you
know before the collapse of communism
where check communists or excuse me Yuka
Slav communists or Romanian Communist
our polish communists are not russian
communist and these the the the fact is
that islamic movements have become the
voice of the opposition many of these
i'm not particularly talking about
turkey but especially in places like
Egypt or Algeria these regimes are tired
bankrupt corrupt you know they came out
of Nasr in the 1950s this pan Arabist
socialist philosophy and it's gone I
mean they are nothing but tired police
states and dictatorships and they will
be swept aside the question is the is
how and if we keep repressing the
opposition as we've seen in countries
like Egypt or Algeria these Islamic
movements grow more and more virulent
and more and more extreme I think the
great failure in Algeria was robbing the
feast the Islamic party of the elections
in 1991 I know the feasts well most of
them were lawyers and doctors I think
that once they it's very easy to be
critical and once you have to govern the
country and and create an viable
economic policy and everything else a
lot of that lust or those utopian
visions are worn off by by by denying
them power by keeping them out of power
you create far more radical and
intransigent groups that are harder to
control so I'm not terribly frightened
about what's happening in Turkey one
must also remember that in Turkey the
army is a
which is secular and really has
traditionally always been opposed to the
Islamists is a very powerful force large
sectors of Turkey are secular and I I
wouldn't be so quick to write someone
off just because they have an Islamic
tag Chris Hedges this is his new book
war is a force that gives us meaning
published by public affairs and
available now nationwide what is this
cover picture it's a picture of people
in brooklyn on the promenade holding up
flags and candles in after the attacks
on the world trade center thanks very
much for coming in this morning I thank
you you're both legs coming we are going
to turn now back to your phone calls and
changing a subject you probably have
heard by now that the president has made
a decision about how he's going to
handle some of the national
you